bonjour nous sommes jeudi 11 décembre
merci de me rejoindre dans fil Eco
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale je vous propose de
commencer tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition
elle a été présentée mercredi au Conseil
des ministres c'est la loi Macron pour
la croissance et l'activité elle prévoit
entre autres l'extension du travail
dominical pour tous les commerces et
cela jusqu'à 12
dimanche une réforme qui pourrait avoir
un impact local important même lorsqu'on
est chef d'entreprise on a besoin de se
former c'est du moins ce que pensent ces
patrons de TPE et de PME en formation
HEC afin d'améliorer leur stratégie
commerciale
le gouvernement veut économiser 50
milliards d'euros d'ici 2017 et localité
française devront ainsi se passer de
près de 3 milliards d'euros en trois ans
nous verrons les conséquences pour les
communes de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
ses alentours
enfin dans notre entretien cette semaine
il sera question de l'association
rencontre pour l'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi en plateau avec nous pour en
parler Isabelle Laurent bonjour vous
êtes la délégué général de cette
association yvinoise vous avez organisé
la deuxième édition de Coup de pouce
pour un emploi au centre commercial
Skywest nous reviendrons avec vous sur
ce forum cette opération mais avant cela
passons en revue l'actualité de la
semaine
je vous disais en titre mercredi la loi
Macron a été présentée au Conseil des
ministres Manuel Valls le Premier
ministre a tenu une grande conférence de
presse afin de présenter ce projet de
loi sur la croissance et l'activité la
réforme la plus médiatique est celle du
travail dominical à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines comme partout
ailleurs les avis sont partagés regardez
avoir le droit de faire ses courses le
dimanche cela ne fait pas l'unanimité le
dimanche c'est un jour pour se reposer
et c'est le jour du Seigneur aussi à
part si c'est pour les périodes de Noël
si les gens veulent acheter des cadeaux
de dernière minute moi je suis pour mais
en temps normal je suis contre ça dépend
des secteurs d'activité il y a des
secteurs d'activité où on demande à
travailler le dimanche comme dans les
aéroports ou dans les gares ou dans les
trains et là les gens n'ont pas le choix
mais
donc voilà enfin je suis globalement
pour le travail dominical il faut aussi
les protéger de toutes éventuel
comment pression pour les inciter pour
les obliger à travailler le dimanche il
faut les protéger de ça mais ça peut
rendre service à des étudiants par
exemple aujourd'hui les commerces
bénéficient de trois types de
dérogations la première soumise à
autorisation municipale ou préfectorale
la deuxième territoriale et enfin la
troisième sectorielle cette dernière
dérogation a fait ses preuves elle
permet au magasin alimentaire
restauration café et hôtel d'ouvrir le
dimanche matin jusqu'à 13h pour les
commerces alimentaires donc ça jeune
personne et puis ça fait toujours des
soins plus et c'est récupérer donc
l'objectif de cette réforme est de
faciliter le travail dominical si cette
mesure est votée elle pourrait concerner
de nombreuses enseignes et centres
commerciaux locaux comme ceux de
Montigny Parly 2 le centre commercial de
Vélizy ou des boutiques de proximité les
mers pourraient autoriser les commerces
plusieurs communes à ouvrir 12 dimanches
par an au lieu de 5 actuellement
je suis plutôt en faveur du travail
dominical dans des dans des secteurs
bien précis au niveau de la ville de
Montigny sur le secteur Skywest qui je
l'espère va redevenir un centre
commercial pour tourner vers le loisir
le volontariat salarial est à la base de
cette réforme elle est censée rendre le
travail dominical plus juste entre les
salariés il recevrait obligatoirement
une compensation mais aussi entre les
commerces des différents territoires on
a un exemple sur la ville de Maurepas
c'est que nous ne sommes pas dans la
zone d'activité ce que nous avons une
grande zone d'activité qui est la zone
d'activité Paris Ouest qui n'est pas en
zone puce alors que la ville de
Coignières l'est ce qui veut dire que la
ville de Maurepas en tout cas les
commerces et les entreprises de la ville
de Maurepas dans la zone Paris Ouest ne
peuvent pas ouvrir le dimanche
et donc ça ça pose un problème
d'inégalité entre les territoires et
donc là il y a une vraie question un
salarié sur trois travaille déjà de
façon
occasionnelle ou régulière le dimanche
le texte sera examiné en janvier par
l'Assemblée mais en mars par le Sénat au
moment des élections départementales
bien souvent les écoles font appel aux
entreprises pour accueillir et
professionnaliser leurs élèves mais là
c'est la situation contraire des chefs
d'entreprise ont décidé de retourner sur
les bancs de l'école mais pas n'importe
laquelle HEC la prestigieuse école de
commerce car même les patrons ont besoin
de formation regardez ce reportage
réalisé avec William L
on commence à rentrer dans une dans une
entreprise
par la proposition de valeur et là il
faut être très très clair studieux
attentif ils ont quitté l'école depuis
longtemps venu sur les bancs de HEC à
Jouy-en-Josas pour se former au
stratégies de dirigeants ses patrons de
petites et moyennes entreprises n'ont
pas fait de grandes écoles de commerce
pour la plupart d'entre eux ici ils
n'apprennent pas à être patron
l'expérience du terrain ils l'ont déjà
acquise l'esprit entrepreneurial on l'a
on l'a pas mais par contre ce qu'il faut
apprendre c'est tous les outils mis à
notre disposition pour être un bon
patron et donc pouvoir aujourd'hui se
battre sur le marché du travail ce sont
des cours très interactifs qui
permettent de confronter bon nombre
d'expériences et d'avoir une vue
beaucoup plus aérienne de ce que l'on
fait au quotidien et surtout de
s'entendre poser des questions
auxquelles on est absolument pas habitué
et qui nous remettent un peu je dirais
en question donc voilà ça c'est très
très intéressant Bruno mocher a monté
son entreprise en 2004 il emploie
aujourd'hui 18 personnes
de formation par an on est là pour pour
mieux comprendre notre marché futur je
suis toujours dans le osé entreprendre
donc avant d'oser il faut y réfléchir
pour faire développer la boîte aux
objets vous pouvez pas rester la tête
dans le guidon faut sortir de votre
contexte et aujourd'hui regarder
ailleurs souvent isolé ces chefs
d'entreprise peuvent ainsi partager leur
expérience et soumettre des
problématiques quotidiennes au formateur
de HEC l'objectif est de réussir à
prendre du recul sur son activité
aujourd'hui stratégie de développement
et performance de l'entreprise sont à
l'ordre du jour on va s'appuyer sur un
certain nombre de réflexions liés à la
réflexion stratégique par exemple
ce que les clients nous achètent et la
façon dont on va satisfaire ses clients
ce sont des sujets qui paraissent
évident mais qui méritent quand même
qu'on y réfléchisse un petit peu mise en
place par la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de Versailles ce partenariat
avec HEC est une première dans les
Yvelines
une bonne nouvelle pour l'économie
yvelinoise le groupe PSA Peugeot Citroën
va investir 153 millions d'euros dont
l'usine Poissy et cela sur la période
2015-2017 cet investissement concerne
principalement une nouvelle plateforme
modulable qui permettra de construire
plusieurs modèles comme les petites
Peugeot 208 ou la Citroën C3 l'usine de
Poissy emploie 5549 salariés je le
rappelle
enfin la société karmat a été primée
lors de la 17ème édition des Trophées de
Limpy l'Institut National de la
propriétaire industrielle l'entreprise
implantait à Vélizy-Villacoublay a été
récompensée lors d'une cérémonie qui
s'est déroulée le 2 décembre elle a reçu
un prix dans la catégorie brevet pour
son cœur artificiel vous le voyez placer
cette année sous le thème de la
mixagénation ça veut dire le mélange de
la tradition et l'innovation c'est
l'ingéniosité du chirurgien cardiaque
pardon Alain Carpentier et l'expertise
des ingénieurs en aéronautique de la
déesse qui sont coupés qui ont été
distinguées
enfin West Yvelines et initiative Val de
Seine pardon voici l'initiative et Val
de Seine initiative deux plateformes du
Mantois et du Val de Seine ont fusionné
l'association couvre maintenant 120
communes du nord des Yvelines
l'événement a été officialisé le 4
décembre lors du premier happy easy
c'est un événement qui a mis cinq
créateurs à l'honneur l'objectif de ce
nouveau rendez-vous et de favoriser les
échanges entre les acteurs de la
création d'entreprise et tout de suite
nous restons dans le monde associatif
dans le monde associatif où nous
continuons avec l'entretien de la
semaine c'est tout de suite
cette semaine nous sommes je le rappelle
avec Isabelle Laurent donc la déléguée
générale de l'association yvinoise
rencontre pour l'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi alors avant d'évoquer le rôle
de votre association je vous propose de
découvrir une de ces actions phares on
peut le dire c'est l'opération coup de
pouce pour l'emploi donc pour la
deuxième fois elle a eu lieu à 50 ans en
Yvelines dans le centre commercial
Skywest en partenariat avec la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines l'occasion
pour les demandeurs d'emploi de
rencontrer directement les recruteurs
regarder ce reportage de William l et
Catherine zulato
Sabine la croix recherche un emploi dans
la vente depuis maintenant deux mois et
demi elle passe un premier entretien
pour intégrer une enseigne de bricolage
à Bois-d'Arcy une dizaine de minutes
pour convaincre c'est plus facile de
venir à des réunions comme ça que que
d'aller dans une entreprise parce que
bon c'est
c'est plus convivial en fait on voit
d'autres personnes on sent moins moins
seul son entretien semble s'être bien
passé elle devrait être rappelée en
début d'année prochaine ici pour cette
enseigne ce sont trois postes
conseillers de vente deux postes
d'employés logistiques et deux postes
d'hôtes clients qui sont proposés la
rencontre directe entre employeurs et
demandeurs d'emploi un vrai plus là le
contact il est direct et c'est bien plus
intéressant pour nous on veut savoir
quelles sont leurs motivations et c'est
pareil c'est un échange il faut qu'il
sache enfin ce qu'on attend nous deux et
qu'elle va être leur mission Didier lui
recherche un travail depuis plus de deux
ans c'est la première fois qu'il vient
un forum de ce type décroché un
entretien une vraie satisfaction pour
lui
ça répond pas on se déplace on fait
attendre une demi-heure et puis il y a
la fin on me dit bah non j'ai pas le
temps aujourd'hui revenir passer plus
rapide là on rencontre directement les
les RH qui donne directement s'ils sont
intéressés ou s'ils sont pas intéressés
c'est plus facile que de faire du
porte-à-porte de tenir un rendez-vous
là il vient de nous voir nous donc on
sait qu'ils sont là pour ça enseigne de
bricolage grande distribution assurance
bâtiment société d'intérim ou encore
fonctions publiques une quinzaine
d'entreprises a répondu présent avec à
la clé des emplois fixes à proposer les
candidats avaient tous eu des ateliers
de préparation aux entretiens car c'est
souvent ceux qui pêche nous intervenons
en amont ce qu'on voit dans les ateliers
de préparation qui sont en difficulté
mais une difficulté naturelle quoi c'est
pas le de pouvoir se présenter de
manière naturelle en mettant en évidence
leurs atouts l'association rencontre
pour l'égalité d'accès à l'emploi
organise quatre à cinq forums de ce type
parent toutes les entreprises présentes
ce jeudi seront rappelés dans une
quinzaine de jours pour dresser un bilan
en moyenne 12% des candidats décrochent
un emploi à l'issue de ses journées
alors tout d'abord Isabelle Laurent je
vais vous demander quel est un peu le
bilan de cette journée vu que donc le
coup de pouce en poids s'est passé
aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui on a 15
entreprises qui sont venues à la
rencontre de 140 jeunes qui avaient été
préalablement invité et préparé par nos
partenaires Pôle Emploi mission locale
et les divers municipaux de l'emploi de
des communes de la Communauté
d'agglomération et voilà et globalement
les entreprises étaient contentes du
travail effectué par les partenaires les
candidats étaient bien ciblés et
les publics le la cible des jeunes en
fait que vous visez c'est plutôt des
jeunes très diplômés pas trop diplômés
vers lesquels vous vous tournez plus
donc notre site c'est un public plutôt
jeune donc 18 35 ans
plutôt peu diplômés de
niveau sans diplôme à bac +2 alors le
coup de pouce emploi donc c'est une des
actions phares dans l'association est-ce
que vous pouvez me la présenter un peu
plus globalement et expliquez-moi ce que
vous faites aussi autour justement à
côté justement de ces coups de pouce
pour l'emploi l'objectif de notre
association c'est de mettre en relation
des jeunes et des entreprises voilà donc
pour ça on a deux grosses activités
phares ces coups de pouce pour un emploi
qui sont des
des genres de forums mais qui sont
tournés vers le candidat c'est à dire
que tout est fait pour que le candidat
soit mise à l'aise et aille à
l'entretien parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte que sur un grand forum classique
le candidat surtout jeune et peu diplômé
il n'y trouvait pas sa place il rentrait
il tournait il prenait des prospectus
mais ne rentrez pas en contact avec le
recruteur donc nous on a mis l'accent
sur l'accueil du candidat et surtout on
commence par une présentation des
entreprises qui démystifient un petit
peu le recruteur c'est à dire que c'est
le recruteur qui s'adresse aux candidats
en premier c'est pas le candidat qui
fait le premier pas pour aller voir le
recruteur et donc ça ça rassure les
jeunes voilà ça rassure ça démystifie et
ça le rassure il s'entend dire par le
recruteur ben voilà le recruteur se
présente présente son entreprise
et puis il dit j'ai besoin de vous je
vous attends venez me voir parce que
voilà si vous avez tel et tel profil
j'ai besoin de vous
comme le public a été préalablement
ciblé et invité forcément ils se
reconnaît dans au moins un des postes et
il va à l'entretien justement c'est une
de vos actions aussi très importante
vous ciblez le public et il y a un il y
a des entretiens en amont vous les
préparez donc voilà on travaille donc
avec les
partenaires locaux parce qu'on travaille
sur tous les Yvelines donc chaque coup
de pouce c'est on travaille avec des
partenaires différents sur la communauté
d'agglomération sur lequel on est donc
avec les Pôle Emploi les missions
locales et puis localement il y a aussi
d'autres associations d'autres des
bureaux municipaux de l'emploi et donc
nous on communique avec on travaille
avec eux en amont sur les postes qui
seront pour voir en leur communique
toutes ces informations et ensuite donc
eux ils informent leur public des postes
des entreprises qui seront présentes des
postes qui aura pour voir et ben là par
exemple sur
sur Saint-Quentin le Pôle emploi la
Mission locale ont mis des informations
collectives en amont
mis en place des ateliers de préparation
à l'entretien type job dating le nouveau
voilà et puis donc les candidats tout ça
ont été invités et sont venus donc en
masse parce que c'est une grande
personne qui sont 240 personnes 140
personnes un nombre important sur parce
que comme c'est ciblé il n'y a pas une
communication à grande échelle c'est
vraiment que des gens qui ont été alors
c'est important pour les entreprises
pour les jeunes qui viennent de vraiment
cibler à qui ça apporte le plus en fait
alors pour les jeunes c'est important
parce que ils ne se déplacent pas pour
rien ils ne s'entendent pas dire bah non
il y a rien pour vous donc ça c'est
important de venir et de d'avoir une
expérience ils sont pas tous embauchés
malheureusement mais ce qu'on veut c'est
tous une expérience enrichissante voilà
et pour les entreprises c'est important
aussi parce qu'elles viennent que sur
une demi-journée
et elles ont
un nombre d'entretien limité mais que
des entretiens ciblés donc elles vont
bien sûr il y aura des bons candidats et
des moins bons mais tous sont ciblés et
voilà c'est ils savent pourquoi ils
viennent globalement et
et l'entreprise voilà quand elle n'a
plus personne
elle peut s'en aller elle est pas
obligée d'attendre comment on commence
par cette présentation des entreprises
tous les candidats sont là au début et
donc quand il y a plus de candidats
l'entreprise peut aussi partir donc elle
n'a pas l'impression de perdre son temps
sur un forum d'attendre un candidat à
une opération un petit peu gagnant voilà
j'ai relevé quelques chiffres vous c'est
votre 24e opération depuis 2008 il y a à
peu près
3500 jeunes qui sont venus donc à ces
opérations et environ voilà 300
candidats qui ont trouvé un emploi grâce
à ses coups de pouce ce sont des
chiffres importants qui sont assez
encourageants il y a beaucoup
d'associations qui qui se font qui se
créent et qui justement accompagnent les
jeunes les aides vers l'emploi est-ce
que du coup voilà vous vous faites un
peu le travail de Pôle emploi c'est ce
qu'on peut dire vous voulez souvent donc
on travaille en partenariat avec eux
on n'a pas la prétention de faire leur
travail sur les coups de pouce nous on
un réseau d'entreprise avec qui on
travaille donc on met à disposition ces
contacts pour les demandeurs d'emploi et
pour pour voilà pour venir en soutien à
Pôle emploi mais pour moi c'est vraiment
un travail complémentaire c'est à dire
que à tout petit échelle alors que Pôle
emploi c'est quand même une grosse
structure nous on intervient vraiment
différemment mais
comment ça parce que vous les aiguillez
vers les emplois vous leur présenter des
recruteurs c'est un peu ce que fait Pôle
Emploi aussi comment mais nous on va
voir quand on fait un accompagnement
individuel en parrainage on va voir un
bénévole qui va s'occuper d'un jeune
pendant 6 mois mais il va s'occuper que
d'un jeune un conseiller Pôle emploi il
va s'occuper de
40 à 800 jeunes en fonction de
de son poste donc enfin jeunes nous
demandeur d'emploi donc c'est sûr que
l'accompagnement ne veut pas être le
même mais dans notre côté nos bénévoles
se sont des gens qui ont l'expérience de
l'entreprise qui ont
mais qui sont pas des professionnels non
plus de l'accompagnement donc pour moi
le travail est vraiment complémentaire
si on veut se faire aider si on veut se
faire accompagner par votre association
comment ça se passe comment ça se
déroule que doit-on faire il faut
m'envoyer son CV ensuite en fonction de
du CV moi je cherche un parrain qui a
une expérience dans ce secteur
d'activité et qui va pouvoir
l'aider donc dans le premier temps ils
ont le candidat un premier entretien
avec le candidat
pour déterminer un peu son objectif et
puis après je recherche un parrain qui
sera mieux à même de l'été ensuite les
candidats qui nous sont envoyés
directement par le conseiller Mission
Locale là c'est le conseiller mission
local qui nous définit la cible
l'objectif du candidat parce qu'il y a
eu un travail qui a été fait déjà avec
lui
alors je vous propose Isabelle Laurent
de regarder avec nous la question de la
semaine vous allez demander à vous cinq
continents en cas de recherche d'emploi
vers qui vous tourneriez vous
je regarderai internet tous les sites du
style Monster quel job enfin il y en a
plein vers une agence d'intérim pour
passer des concours
de tête peu importe la société parce
qu'ils vont être plus proactif et on
aura pour avoir un interlocuteur pour
pour avoir des retours sur nos
candidatures internet tous les sites de
recherche de moteur de recherche
Internet Monster job rapido enfin tous
ces sites aujourd'hui avec les sites
internet de recrutement etc on peut tout
faire que ce soit même avec les réseaux
sociaux LinkedIn
alors Isabelle Laurent une réaction par
rapport à ce que vous venez de voir
alors je suis d'accord que l'Internet
prend beaucoup de place aujourd'hui sur
sur la recherche d'emploi il y a
beaucoup d'offres qui sont offertes sur
sur Internet d'un autre côté le
demandeur d'emploi a tendance à
s'enfermer derrière son ordinateur et
c'est aussi un gros risque de rester
enfermé derrière son ordinateur et
justement ce que peut apporter une
association c'est de rompre cette
solitude et d'échanger avec quelqu'un et
d'avoir un retour un miroir
vis-à-vis de sa recherche d'emploi il y
a très bien merci merci beaucoup
Isabelle Laurent d'être venu sur notre
plateau il est temps maintenant de
passer au chiffre de la semaine
- 4,3% c'est la baisse de l'effectif de
l'emploi intérimaire dans les Yvelines
par rapport au mois d'octobre 2013 ce
sont les chiffres donc du mois d'octobre
2014 qui ont été rendu public début
décembre par le baromètre par le
baromètre prisme emploi en Île-de-France
il faut savoir que l'emploi intérimaire
recule de 0,4% chez les cadres et
professions intermédiaires il progresse
de 10,5%, mais reculent beaucoup chez
les ouvriers qualifiés national
nationalement ce sont les travaux
publics les BTP qui enregistrent une
chute très importante
parlons maintenant budget et économie au
pluriel c'est l'heure de notre dossier
la semaine
le projet de loi pour les finances 2015
est au cœur de l'actualité le
gouvernement doit faire 50 milliards
d'économies cela va directement impacter
les communes françaises car l'état
réduit leur dotation globale de
fonctionnement à 50 ans en Yvelines et
ses communes aux alentours les
conséquences sont plus ou moins
importantes regardez ce tour d'horizon
réalisé avec Mélanie Boquet et Romain
Rossini
- 3,7 milliards d'euros en 2015 même
diminution en 2016 puis en 2017 les
baisses de dotation touchent toutes les
communes françaises sur trois ans ces
11,1 milliard d'euros en moins à
percevoir pour les collectivités à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on s'organise
la plus grande commune avec plus de
34135 habitants c'est
Montigny-le-Bretonneux la mairie prévoit
pour 2015 une baisse de 1 million
d'euros dans le budget on avait déjà
fait un réel effort et en fait depuis un
certain temps un réel effort sur nos
coups de fonctionnement donc nous on
arrive à le faire cette année sans
augmentation d'impôts sans réduire les
services à la population et en
conservant le même montant si non plus
d'investissement que les autres années
sur trois ans la Ville estime perd près
de 3 millions d'euros soit une année
entière d'investissement bien que ce
secteur précis ne devrait pas être
impacté même constat et conséquences
différentes pour Élancourt avec un
impact de 3 millions d'euros en trois
ans la ville de 26834 voit son budget
amputé de
30%. nous Élancourt on a mis au
congélateur d'une part la piste de
projet de piste de ski aménagement de la
colline d'Élancourt deuxièmement le
projet d'un stade également on avait
quasiment attribué le marché en or je
sais c'est on est obligé de congeler
également ce projet de ce nouveau
gymnase Lionel Terray on va pas non plus
engager les projets on pourra pas payer
donc on gèle ces deux grandes communes
50 chinoises promettent de ne pas
répercuter ses baisses sur les impôts
des habitants mais toutes les villes ne
pourront pas en faire autant les
conséquences sont beaucoup plus lourdes
et immédiates pour les petites communes
comme la verrière qui compte environ
6000 habitants
au titre de la culture on va réduire la
programmation va supprimer des dates de
concert on va réduire les manifestations
on va supprimer
on réduit du personnel du coup aussi il
y a des postes qu'on ne renouvelle pas
dans le domaine de la culture des
maisons quartiers par exemple aussi on a
touché à l'action de quartier parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à maintenir toutes
les activités les dotations de l'État
pour les collectivités locales
représentent un tiers des ressources des
communes dont une majeure partie est
allouée aux dépenses de fonctionnement
pour les communautés moyennes environ
9000 habitants à Manille et 13000 à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux la baisse de
dotation sèche-lonne entre 300 et 350
000 euros l'état finalement devient la
partie neutre du jeu et renvoie la balle
à l'ensemble des élus locaux qui
essayent eux de mettre en place tous les
services de proximité dont ont besoin
les habitants pour les communes il
s'agit aussi de participer à l'effort de
réduction d'endettement parce que ça
nous concerne nous mais ça concerne
aussi les générations à venir et donc
je pense que nous pouvons faire cet
effort un voisin peut faire cet effort
des efforts la commune de voisins ont
fait déjà pour ne pas impacter les
habitants la vie a choisi de mutualiser
certaines dépenses une initiative qui se
pratique de plus en plus dans les
Yvelines aujourd'hui on est tenu et on
est obligé d'avoir cette attitude
justement par rapport à ces baisses qui
vont qui s'opèrent pour pouvoir avoir
une gestion saine de regarder
effectivement je poste par poste les
points sur lequel on peut faire des
économies on vient de rentrer là par
exemple c'est un exemple sur un
groupement d'achat qui va nous permettre
de faire des achats dans le groupe et
comme son nom l'indique pour obtenir
effectivement des économies sur des
consommables ou sur sur des
investissements spécifiques à chaque
groupe et mutualisation des services ou
gestion au millimètre cela suffira-t-il
à Bois-d'Arcy pour compenser les 200.000
euros de dotation globale de
fonctionnement en moins pour 2015 à
Maurepas on espère aussi réduire les
dépenses de 25% et investir dans le
patrimoine vieillissant la commune voit
ses dotations diminuées de 600 000 euros
pour 2015 pourtant comme nombre de
collectivités elle doit faire face à des
dépenses incompressibles je ne vous
cache pas que ça va être très compliqué
la réforme des rythmes scolaires à
financé
plus l'augmentation du glissement
vieilles technicité pour payer les
agents donc tout ça un impact fort sur
le budget communal fin novembre le Sénat
a modifié le projet de loi des finances
pour 2015 la baisse des dotations a été
ramenée à 2,0 6 milliards d'euros contre
les 3,67 milliards d'euros prévus à
l'origine par le gouvernement adopté
mardi par le Sénat le projet de loi très
modifié par la majorité de droite sera
toutefois examinée par une commission
mixte paritaire
et nous suivrons ce dossier avec
attention c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivi je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de Philippo et ce sera le
dernier de l'année 2014 alors ne le
ratez pas je vous souhaite une très
bonne fin de soirée